scp-682 vs scp-294  the hard to destroy reptile versus the  coffee machine could this supernatural  keurig brew up a final victory over this  ordinary reptile researchers got the  machine to dispense  scp-682 killer and poured it onto a  tissue sample the sample crumbled into a  fine powder when it made contact with  the liquid so they cumulatively brewed  up a liter of the stuff and poured it on  the actual  scp-682 the affected areas decayed and  crumbled just like in the test and when  scp-682 was placed back into its acid  tank the area is completely dissolved  the researchers felt incredibly hopeful  believing that if a large enough  quantity of scp-682 killer can be  synthesized it may actually live up to  its name we'll let you know as soon as  they try it again with a venti order